مرحبًا
[موسيقى]
أنت امرأة لديها طفل تحاول
دخول الولايات المتحدة عن طريق عبور نهر ريو جراند
بينما كان الحرس الوطني في تكساس
يراقب ولكن لم
يتدخل في النهاية، تشق المرأة
طريقها عائدة إلى الجانب المكسيكي والطفل
في يدها في  وفي بيان لشبكة CNN،
قالت الإدارة العسكرية في تكساس إن
جنود الحرس الوطني في تكساس اقتربوا
بالقارب وقرروا أنه لا توجد
علامات على إصابة طبية أو
عجز وكان لديهم القدرة
على العودة لمسافة قصيرة إلى
الشاطئ المكسيكي، وبقي الجنود في
الموقع ل  نهاية مراقبة الوضع،
كما اقتبس قارب جوي تابع لهيئة الجمارك وحماية الحدود الأمريكية مرور المرأة والطفل
دون توقف، وقد تواصلت CNN مع إدارة الجمارك وحماية الحدود
للحصول على تعليق.